estelle bonjour alors ultime
concertation avant la mise en place de
cette réforme contestée
et oui covit 19 oblige la mise en
application de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage avait été repoussée plusieurs
fois mais à un an de la présidentielle
elisabeth bornes la ministre du travail
l'a martelé elle est déterminée à aller
au bout de cette réforme mais dans une
version adaptée à la crise sanitaire
alors cette réunion aujourd'hui elle va
permettre à la ministre de présenter aux
partenaires sociaux ses arbitrages le
décret devrait ensuite être publiés
courant mars pour une application à
l'été 2000 21 et des discussions qui
risque d'être tendu estelle ce matin
exactement magali car les syndicats ont
déjà exprimé leurs doutes sur cette
réforme dans un communiqué commun les
cinq organisations syndicales comme la
cfdt la cgt ou encore et fo ont
réaffirmé je cite leur profond désaccord
avec le principe fondateur de cette
réforme selon laquelle la baisse des
allocations chômage ainsi très un retour
plus rapide à l'emploi globalement les
syndicats y voient une opportunité pour
le gouvernement de faire des économies
budgétaires aux dépens des demandeurs
d'emploi estelle qu'est ce qui va
changer finalement concrètement alors
deux mesures seront directement liées à
l'état du marché de l'emploi tout
d'abord les conditions et d'éligibilité
aux allocations il faudra avoir
travaillé au moins est six mois au cours
des deux dernières années pour en
bénéficier
actuellement ces quatre mois au cours
des 28 derniers mois
la dégressivité de la location elle
aussi sera ali
l état de santé du marché du travail en
revanche l'été prochain de mesures
entreront en vigueur peu importe l'état
de santé de l'économie le nouveau mode
de calcul de l'indemnisation ainsi selon
l'unedic 4 allocataires sur dix
devraient voir leurs allocations baissé
de 22% en moyenne
et puis il ya ce fameux système de malus
pour les entreprises qui abusent à des
contrats précaires ce malus ne sera
appliquée en revanche encore 2022 après
avoir observé le comportement de ces
entreprises pendant un an sachez que
c'est la seule mesure acceptée par les
syndicats pour ainsi dire n'est cette
fois c'est le patronat qui s'y opposent
merci beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
explications mesure qui ne concerne pas
le chômage partiel précisons le